hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled evaluating tumor
immune cell interactions in human lung
cancer using multi-parametric and
spatially resolved
tissue analysis i'm susie valdez of
labrus and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by fluidim
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into
the ask a question box and click send we
will answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on that ask the question
box located on the far left of your
screen
i now present today's speaker dr kurt
chilper an assistant professor of
pathology
and the director of translational immuno
oncology laboratory at yale school of
medicine
for a complete biography on dr schulper
please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
welcome dr schulper you may now begin
your presentation
hello first of all i would like to thank
the organizers for inviting me to give
this presentation
and the title of my talk is evaluating
tumor immune cell interactions in human
lung cancer using
multi-parametric and spatial result
tissue analysis
these are my disclosures
so in the next 25 minutes or so we will
discuss four general topics first
we'll briefly analyze um key concepts
and challenges for anti-cancer
immunotherapy and
and discuss a little bit how we may help
overcoming some of those challenges
using
analysis of human samples in the second
part
i will discuss some of the data we have
produced over the last years
using spatially resolved tissue analysis
to understand
the tumor and immune composition
particularly of non-small cell lung
cancers
which is the topic of the research in my
lab
in the third part i will share with you
some advances
using extended panels to interrogate
both
tumor and immune cells instantly using
imaging mass cytometry again in
non-muscle lung cancer
and i will close with a few conclusions
and future directions
so most of the current um active
immunotherapies
rely on two major immune inhibitory
pathways
uh namely ctla4 which is indicated on
the
left side of the slide and pd-1pdl1
which is on the right
side while we believe that the ctla4
pathway
acts more on the priming stage of the
immune response usually happening
happening in lymphoid tissue organs
there really know little about it and
there's still many questions about the
mechanism of action and what are
determinants for sensitivity and
resistance
as opposed to that the pd-1 pdl1 pathway
is believed to
have a major role directly in the tumor
microbiome and more at the effector
stage
of the adaptive anti-tumor immune
response um and and still there are many
questions about what are the
determinants
what are the mechanism of action uh and
obviously the major question is how to
overcome
the limitations of these treatments to
try to
expand the use of the cancer
immunotherapy
one of the major considerations relative
to this presentation
is that regardless of the use of
multiple
model systems to interrogate anti-tumor
immune responses
it has been extremely challenging to
completely recapitulate
the complexity of the immune response in
vitro or even in animal models
and i won't go into deep details but
essentially every
model that has been used has major
limitations so this is really a call
for the opportunity of learning from
real human tumors
uh interrogating them in more advanced
ways
another important concept that i think
it's critical to move the field forward
is to try to decipher what is the role
and what is the
regulation of the tumor microenvironment
and as you can see here from a real
lung cancer picture on the left using
hematoxylineosin
and a cartoon on the right it is very
clear
that the tumor microenvironment is a
very complex
place composed of multiple structures
and cell types that are arranged in a
very particular manner
and actually becomes a very difficult
place to study
and it's probably critical to understand
this because it changes
a lot between patients across tumors
before and after treatment so it's kind
of a dynamic place
but also it's because um or is the place
where most of the tumor immune
interaction happens
and are likely to govern um the success
of the immune cell clearing
another important concept is the idea
that there are two
sort of major type of tumors across the
board
once we called non-inflamed or cold
tumors which are generally
not very prominent immune filtration
and then there is the other extreme
which we generally call t cell inflamed
tumors or hot tumors
which we typically see a high
immunofiltration and pdl pdl1 expression
while this conceptual category was very
helpful to
sort of initiate the development of the
anti-cancer immunotherapy
and actually i was one of the proposals
of this
model i think now we're learning that uh
these are really the extremes of a long
continuous
and it becomes very difficult now to
really define
what is the limit between a hog and a
cold tumor
and where should we draw a line this is
particularly
notable when we start using um
continuous and quantitative analysis
where it's much more complicated to
define
what is above or below certain threshold
and this is an example that we have
reported in lung cancer where you can
see that
we generally assign semi-quantitative
scores but we really see a big
range of tumors where we have virtually
no t-cells recognized by
visual analysis or we have very high
t-cells but really what defines here
what is a hot
or a biologically hot and cold tumor is
still
a matter of questions and also i will
show you that not every t-cell inflamed
tumor
is actually the same so now
moving into what is the role and the
potential of using spatial resolve
analysis
my team has been doing this type of work
for a long time now
mostly using multiplex
immunofluorescence and we have
focus or analysis and try to identify
dominant immunization pathways and this
is an example
of a study we published a number of
years ago where we look at
candidate immunotherapy ligands or
targets
that were upregulated in immune cells
and as you can see here
in this picture where tumor cells are
highlighted with
green cytokeratine and the targets with
red we are able to find
that interestingly most of the tumors
that had very high levels of markers
such as pda one
idea one or even b7 h4 generally had
lower levels of the other markers
and this was interesting because at this
point we didn't know
if markers such as pdl one were
generally co-expressed with multiple
other candidate immunotherapy targets or
pathways
and what we found was actually that that
was not the case and in lung cancer
mostly tumors seem to upregulate or
prominently
regulate one major immunization pathway
and not multiple
at a time and this is actually quite
noticeable for this particular
combination of target this is a
confocal imaging using b7h3 and b7h4
where we look at this again the presence
of tumor cells looking at green
cytokeratine
and you can see here again a confocal
resolution that
there is essentially mutual exclusivity
in the pattern of expression
of these two targets in cancer cells
which is generally not by chance
um so this at least suggests that tumor
cells in general
uh evade uh or upregulate the immune
innovation molecules in a dominant
fashion
uh but but they not necessarily have
multiple
upregulated at a time so figuring out
what is the role of this
in uh cancer immunization and
potentially in treatment sensitivity
uh it's a major challenge in addition to
look at the tumor cell
expression of targets we started
interrogating the tumor microenvironment
and this is an example of a multiplex
amino fluorescence panels
where we were able to look at tumor
cells in this case again with green
cytokeratine
and then multiple tumor infiltrating
lymphocyte substances you can see here
cd4
in red staining helper t cells cd8 in
yellow staining
cytotoxic t cells and then cd20 a diesel
marker
in white so you can see here that we can
not only
spatially resolve the contextual of the
tumor but we can also quantitatively
count
the signal for each of those markers and
then uh
obviously study the association of those
metrics relative to clinical outcomes
in addition to be able to detect
individual cell populations and and
measure them we also develop panels to
interrogate
functional aspects of these cells and
this is an example of a panel where
we were able to measure cytokeratine
again a tumor marker tumor epithelial
marker with yellow
in this case t cells a pan diesel marker
cd3 with red
and then we are able to measure a
proliferation marker k67
and a cytolytic marker grand sign b so
now
by colocalizing these markers we can
reliably measure the proliferation of t
cells or tumor cells by looking at k-67
or the cytolytic activity of t-cells by
looking at grand sin b over c d three
positive t cells
so using this type of analysis we first
interrogated the relationship between
baseline t-cell activation and
proliferation
and outcomes after pd-1 axis blockers in
patients with lung cancer
and what you can see here on the slide
are the main results from the study
where we were actually very surprised to
find that
the apparently the tumors that are more
sensitive to immunostimulatory therapies
are not the ones that are poorly
inflamed on the left
or very highly inflamed and highly
activated and proliferating tails on the
right
the most sensitive are actually
somewhere in between there seem to be a
window
of t-cell activation that it's more
physiological or normal
in which patients are sensitive so what
you're seeing here
are the patients with low t-cell
infiltration or cold tumors if you want
and these are indicated with the blue
survival curve and you can see that
they're do very poorly after pd-1 axis
blockers
which is something we kind of know at
this point but the surprise was that the
tumors with
extremely high activation and
proliferation which are indicated with
the red survival curve are also
not getting a lot of benefit and again
the tumors that have prominent
immunofiltration with
moderate or now we're starting to call
normal t-cell activation and
proliferation are the ones that get the
most benefit
which is the green survival curve so
this actually
led us to propose that there is within
the inflamed tumors there is a subset
that have this
dysfunctional t-cell activation and now
a lot of people are calling the term of
exhausted t cells or terminal
differentiated t cells
which is consistent or apparently
consistent across tumors
then we also got interested in trying to
understand
what were the dominant regulatory
pathways in those uh
dysfunctional t cells so we started
looking at things that were potentially
actionable
and we first focus on pd1 team 3 and lab
3
that are known to be immune inhibitory
receptors expressed in activated t cells
so the first thing we did to map
out the relevance and the functional
context of these markers
was to use a comprehensive approach
using a single cell
analysis by the site of platform so this
is actually the suspension based site of
we created a 37 marker panel
looking at a phenotype and functional
immune system markers
and then we obtain samples from 20
primary
human lung cancers that well
disaggregated and
analyzed using this site of panel
so the first thing we look at was that
the distribution of the three
immune inhibitor receptors pd-1 lag
three and team three
and as you can see here was not
surprising to see that most of the pd-1
was allocated to
t cells cd4 cd8 and t-rex but there was
also some pd1 expression in
nkt cells lac3 as expected was
highly expressed on cd8 positive t cells
as you can see here
and there was some expression in other
t-cell subsets
there was also high levels in natural
and nkt cells and
some expression in granulocytes which
were trying to understand the role
interestingly for team three the
landscape was very different
and the majority of the signal was
actually not detected in t
cells but on myeloid cells and dendritic
cells as you can see here
so this was actually a surprise when we
initially
uh looked at this data what was most
interesting about this
is that when we look at the extremes of
the t-cell population
relative to these markers so the ones
that co-expressed or upregulated
together cp1 lack three and team three
compared to the ones that didn't express
pd1 like three and team three
we found a very prominent functional
difference
and as you can see here in the heat map
but also i think the individual marker
level
we found that those t cells expressing
the three
immune inhibitory receptors had
consistently higher levels of activation
markers such as cd69
or 401 bb or cd137 but also high markers
of proliferation
um k67 and cytolytic activity which is
grand sign b
this was very consistent with what we
already found relative to this
hyper activated or dysfunctional t cells
in the tumor microenvironment
what was interesting and quite novel was
that we were able to also see that those
cells
had signs of dysfunction and in this
case noted as
upregulation of very clear pro-apoptotic
proteins fast and bim
so this at least suggests that the cost
may be of
extreme activation and proliferation is
the up regulation of cell death programs
and this
could explain why these cells are
actually dysfunctional and they're
insensitive
to current pd-1 inhibitors
we then look at the tissue validating a
panel for these markers
and as you can see here we found very
consistently that black 3 and pd1
were predominantly expressed in cd3
positive t cells
we're also able to now confirm in tissue
that the team 3 signal was predominantly
allocated
to non-cd3 positive cells in the tumor
bed consistent with
macrophages and you can see here many of
them expressing high levels of tim3
however we do see again some signal in
cd3 positive t cells
to understand what was the role or the
potential link between
the expression of this inhibitory
receptors and sensitivity and resistance
to pd-1 axis blockers
we actually look at baseline samples
from 90 patients with lung cancer
treated with pd-1 axis blockers in our
institution
and what we're able to find is that up
regulation or dominant expression of
black 3 in t
cells at baseline was actually clearly
associated with
lower outcome after pd-1 axis blockers
and we didn't see the same effect for
pd-1 or team 3.
another interesting aspect is that the
effect
of up regulation of black three and t
cells was independent from the effect of
pdl1
and you can see here in panel d that the
the tumors with low lag three and high
pdl one did really well
after pd1 blockade but the ones that had
high lac3
and low pdl1 did the worst again
supporting that the pd-1 pathway
and the lag3 pathway are independent and
potentially complementary
one important question about lag three
that has been out there for a while
uh is the the the nature of the
candidate or potential ligands that
could activate this receptor
and i won't go into too much detail now
but in collaboration with the lab of
leaping chen
we are able actually to discover and
characterize
the major black three ligand relevant in
lung cancer which is called fgl1 or
fibrinogen like protein one
and this was work done again by june 1
in leaping chennai
and we were able to show that this
ligand was not only
powerful in cancer but it was also up
regulated in a fraction
of human tumors so this is really
opening the doors to understand
the lac3fgl1 pathway in depth and
potentially support
development of treatments
so now we wanted to move on and try to
integrate
the tumor metrics the t cell metrics and
maybe other functional aspects into a
single panel
and this was really hard to do in a
comprehensive manner using multiplexing
uniforstance which we can accommodate
maybe up to seven or eight markers
reliably
so to address this question we moved on
to a different
uh physics and technology in this case
we use imaging mass cytometry
which as opposed to immunofluorescence
uses
uh mass spectrometry and and rare earth
metals as a signal detection
so in a in a nutshell what we do here we
conjugate primary antibodies that are
known to work in paraffin tissue or
validated to work in paraffin tissue
and we incubate them all together with
this sample
and then they're activated with a 213
laser nanometer laser very sharply of
each micron in the tissue
and that produces little iron clouds
that are flown through an inert gas
chamber
and then resolved by mass effect to be
relocated to each
micron or pixel where they were obtained
so we can really obtain a one micron
resolution microscopic image of the
tissue
but then looking at multiple markers and
just as a node you can see here the
spectral overlap of fluorescence
which is generally a big problem to
allocate many markers
and and separate the signal uh relative
to imaging mass cytometry where
the spill over between the channels each
must much less prominent and allow
a better resolution of mult multiple
markers
so what i will show you next is the
preliminary result from the first panel
which we called
gale imc immune oncology panel one
in which we included 29 markers that are
indicating this table including some
structural components that we generally
use for tissue segmentation
then we use self-phenotypic markers to
highlight uh
different cell populations we also added
some functional markers to understand
the the functional profile of those
cells and then a number of candidate
immunotherapy targets that we expected
to be present
in tumor and immune cells
so this is just a quick example of
validation orthogonal validation of
tissue analysis using
immunofluorescence which again we have
validated extensively and used for years
relative to imaging mass cytometry and
this is just a representative lung
cancer tissue
where we actually did the
immunofluorescence using a metal
conjugated antibody
and then the same tissue was brought to
the imc instrument and laser appellated
so this is actually the very same tissue
and the very same cells
and just to select a few markers we put
here cytokeratine in green
cd3 in red and a dna nuclear marker in
blue
but you can see already that the pattern
of staining and the location of the
markers and the even the intensity are
quite comparable
using the two platforms which is again
an indication
of the efficacy and the the capacity
that we have to use
this technology to analyze tissues
so this is now an example of a human
lung cancer
stained with this 29 marker panel
and we break this into multiple sub
panels with different markers but you
can see here for example in panel one
that the tumor cells again are positive
for green cytokeratine
and they show a high level of
proliferation revealed as the white k67
then cd3 positive diesels are in the
stroma
and then we can start allocating other
markers so essentially what i'm trying
to show here is that we have spatial
context we can
select areas where to measure but we are
also producing a lot of data because we
can either measure this in a compartment
base
or a single cell-based model
so this is an example of using um
non-commercial software or or
freeware where we have been able to
analyze the tissue using a single cell
modality so this is
uh segmentation using the nuclear signal
you can see here
how we can create individual cell frames
and then we can actually call the
phenotype from all the markers
extracting the individual cell
phenotypes so this is a
t-sniplot including multiple cell
phenotypes from multiple cases but
really we can get here to the several
thousands and even millions of cells
and each of them has a spatial
allocation and annotation
another way of looking at this is to
instead of looking in an unbiased manner
of multiple cell phenotypes we can
actually select
compartments based on the expression of
particular markers
so this is an example now where we broke
into two panels using the markers are
indicated here
and we selected tumor and stromal areas
by the
expression or absence of cytokeratine
so you can see here how we selected the
tumor compartment using
cytokeratin in this case highlighted in
red and then we individualized the cells
using histone 3
to obtain both a compartment in this
case the tumor compartment
and then individual cell phenotypes
using
other markers
so when doing this analysis the first
thing we look at
was a cohort of patients treated with
immunotherapy
so these are again baseline specimens
but we knew the outcome of those
patients so we knew they responded to
immunotherapy in this case we call them
durable clinical benefit which are
indicated in blue
and then there were patients that didn't
respond to immunotherapy or had a very
short stable disease
less than six months which are indicated
in red and we called no
durable benefit so when we collected
individual cd8 positive t cells
and we stratified them by the clinical
outcomes
we clearly were able to see that as
expected and
as i showed you with fluorescence and
siteof uh those uh
tumors that are less sensitive to
immunotherapy
generally displayed t cells that had
higher levels of activation
and but also higher levels of exhaustion
and dysfunction and they were
characterized by
elevated levels of black 3 team 3 pd1
but also cd25 a proliferation marker k67
red sign b and even high levels of
receptors cd3 and cda so again this is
consistent with the idea that
uh tumors from patients that are
insensitive to treatment generally have
t cells with a hyperactivation or
dysfunction
and terminal differentiation the
interesting thing is that because of
these extended panels we're able now to
simultaneously
look at tumor cells that are positive
for cytokeratine and again here we
selected cells based on both the
expression of cytokeratine and also
morphological features
and what was very interesting is that we
were able to see that again
there were prominent phenotypic
difference in the tumor cells between
patients that were sensitive
to pd-1 axis blockers and insensitive so
what you can see here is that in general
tumors from patients that were
insensitive again in red
they generally had tumors with high dna
markers in this case histone 3 but also
high proliferation
and also less differentiation
characterized by lower levels of
cytokeratine and high levels of the
mesenchymal marker by menting
notably the tumors from insensitive
patients also differentially upregulated
multiple immune inhibitory pathways such
as cd47
b7 h3 b7 h4 and vista
so again this shows that there is a
clear
tumor phenotype associated with this
t-cell dysfunction and also resistance
to immune checkpoint blockers
so one important point about analyzing
the tissue
using the spatial context is that
segmenting the tissue in a reliable
manner is actually a very difficult task
it's very difficult to achieve a high
level or high
grade segmentation but it's also very
time consuming
and cumbersome so to actually overcome
some of these
limitations we generated a machine
learning algorithm
that was segmentation independent so
what we look at here was
uh in uh very similar to what we do when
we do
google maps or when we look at the
profile of a city
looking at the skyline or the peaks of
the building heights
so using a similar principle we
generated the machine learning algorithm
to detect the high peaks of signals
across the tissue
without having to segment but being able
to locate
the little neighborhoods associated with
the peaks of signal intensity for
all the markers or multiple markers
and to tell a long story short what we
found using multiple
algorithms and trainings is that there
were certain patterns that were enriched
in patients that were resistant to
immunotherapy
which are indicated by accumulation of
these red little patches
and very few of the blue patches and
then there were accumulation
of other little patches or neighborhoods
in patients that were sensitive that you
can see as an example here
that were generally these blue patches
and very few of the red patches
so again this allow us to locate little
neighborhoods including tumor and immune
cells that were
differentially expressed in patients
that were sensitive and resistant
and this was regardless of the tissue
segmentation
so to prove or test the performance of
this stratification method we actually
look at the
segregation of responders and
non-responders using this model
and as you can see on the upper left in
a 3d disney plot
where the responders are indicated in
yellow and the non-responders in blue
we are able to clearly separate
spatially those patients or most of the
patients that we're
sensitive and insensitive to treatment
again these
samples are used at baseline and this
was clearly not by chance
because we didn't see any segregation
when we just put the patients in the
order
at which they were acquired so clearly
there was a non-random
distribution relative to the clinical
outcomes
so then to validate this we actually
look at another cohort but we also did
uh believe went out cross-validation
using an informatic approach
and using this model we were actually
able to find
or accurate or predict accurate response
or resistance in nearly 87 percent of
patients which is really
much higher than what we can do today
using other markers such as pdl-1
tumor mutational burden or t cells alone
and as expected this separation was
associated with outcomes
which is shown on the progression-free
survival
so in conclusion i hope i convince you
that resistance to immunotherapy
can be both mediated by antitumor
pressure and
deregulated activation of t cells and
and really
what we know now um mostly after this
data is that
the resistance to immunotherapy can be
tumor-mediated
what i call tumor privilege typically
associated with defective
anti-representation we have we have
shown in
other publications but also changes in
tumor differentiation
and and also up regulation of
alternative regulatory pathways
but also resistance can be immune
mediated and this is what i call
immune tolerance where we at least can
see
clearly diesel immune dysfunction
characterized by
terminal differentiation and exhaustion
of those t cells
but also maybe engagement into a diesel
death
or apoptotic programs which is what i
just showed you for uh
up regulation of the lack three of gl1
pathway and there may be other
mechanisms
uh that are involved and now i think we
have enough evidence that these two may
be
related and this is something to also be
explored in the future
um and interestingly what i didn't show
you is that we have seen some of these
phenotypes also associated with acquire
resistance so this may not be
uh able to explain primary resistance
but also maybe
acquired or secondary resistance
so in conclusion i hope i convince you
that biomarkers can support and
arguably should be used to select
patients for anti-cancer immunotherapy
and i think it's not
very optimistic that the way we are
currently using immunotherapy is pretty
much like chemotherapy
um second i think we have convincing
evidence that resistance to
immunostimulatory therapy can be both
tumor and immune mediated
and there may be actually links between
these two programs that needs to be
addressed
third that the lac3 fgl1 pathway may be
a dominant immunization pathway in a
fraction of non-small cell lung cancers
and this could be therapeutically
exploited by perhaps selecting
patients with this dominant biology and
submit them to treatments targeting this
pathway selectively
fourth that uh the analysis of tumor and
immune contextual
can support understanding sensitivity
and resistance to immune checkpoint
blockers
and that there's clearly the potential
to integrate the signal to hopefully
develop better biomarkers in the future
for both clinical use and perhaps for
drug development and finally their
prominent
developments allowing deep analysis of
intact tumor specimens i just show you
the data with imaging mass cytometry
and there is a lot of potential for
discovery using
this type of approaches and also using
advanced bioinformatics
to be able to retrieve the meaningful
signal
and then hopefully contribute um to to
treat better our patients
so with that i would like to end and
acknowledge the people who are actually
doing the work that i just
presented so a lot of knowledge into my
lab and these
are my current lab members former lab
members a lot of which contributed to
the work that i just shared
and then obviously internal
collaborators external collaborators
and the funding sources and i will be
happy to take questions
thank you
and thank you so much dr schulber for
that informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started it looks like we
have some questions already coming in
from our audience thank you so much for
your participation
dr schulper our first question is
is there any relationship between hot
cold tumors in an up regulation
of a particular tumor marker
yes so so can you hear me
i can yeah okay so so yeah that's a
great question and i think we're just
starting to discover
uh elements in the tumor that somehow
govern
or interact with the tumor immune
contextual
at this point we know from a few genetic
events
that are clearly associated with the the
likelihood of that tumor to be more or
less inflamed
some of which are well-known kinase
mutations such as egfr
k ras alk and ross and this is specific
for lung cancer we generally see that
those tumors driven by
kinase are generally less t cell
inflamed
and there are other things such as new
or recently discovered genes such as
sdk11 lkb1 that have been shown to also
be commonly associated with uh poorly
inflamed tumors
uh so that's from the genomic standpoint
i think the the from the phenotypic
example we're just
uh learning that that there are some
programs also associated with high or
low inflamed tumors but
i think this is still to be the
determined and to be
implemented
thank you so much this next question
from our audience number
is a two-part question how are
antibodies
for imc validated and do antibodies
validated for ihc or if work
yeah so this is a very important
question because uh most of the
antibodies that are commercially
available are not necessarily suitable
for
paraffin uh formally fixed parts in
embedded tissue so
so the question here circles back to the
notion that before
thinking about using things like imc we
need to make sure that the antibodies
work in formally fixed and paraffin
embedded tissue
and that then allows them to be
standardized using imc
so the short answer is that if the
antibody has been validated
for ihc or immunofluorescence they
should
work with no problem in imc if the
antibodies have not been validated for
formally fixed paraffin embedded tissue
they need to be validated before
being used
thank you so much and i again want to
thank our audience for their questions
coming in we have time for a couple more
questions
dr shelter how is the sensitivity of imc
relative to other methods
yeah so so the there are differences in
the
sensitivity that can be achieved uh
compared to ioc or immunofluorescent and
that depends on the
detection system being used in general
when we use immunofluorescence or ic we
use polymers or dextrans that amplify a
lot the signal
with imc we believe that we're including
about 100
metals per antibody uh in that varies a
little bit depending on the conjugation
but that's a fair bit of sigma
amplification so
um i think at this point using the top
amplification system
in fluorescent we may achieve a higher
sensitivity than imc
but imc uses a sensitivity that it's in
the range of a hundred and maybe a
little bit more than 100
tax per antibody so there is high
sensitivity and amplification
uh but probably not so much a certain uh
amplification system that can be used in
fluorescence
thank you we have time for one more
question
what is the optimal tissue
area size for analysis using imc
yeah so this is an important question
because it has to do with the
the throughput of the technology so one
of the things
we do now generally we use imc to
analyze relatively small tissue areas
and that has to do with the
sort of time required to analyze
so we generally use this as a discovery
tool and i think at this point uh using
tissue microarrays or prioritizing
relatively small tissue areas it's
important to achieve a reasonable
throughput
and i think proposing studies using
analysis of a whole tissue section still
still i think that we're a little early
to to actually get that back
thank you dr schoper i want to thank you
again for your presentation today
and for your important research would
you like to provide the audience with
any final comments before we close today
yeah so i think i i hope i convince
everyone that
analyzing human tumors and the immune
contextual is an important task
we can learn a lot and i think the the
future for
specially resolved tissue analysis is
beautiful it's bright and i think there
is a lot to do
thank you and thank you very much sir
i'd also like to thank flu dine for
sponsoring today's event and i want to
encourage the audience members to listen
to other presentations as part of this
day
and explore the fluid fluidized virtual
environment and their boost
and before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us and for their
interesting questions
and questions we didn't have time for
today and those submitted on the demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via contact information
be provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through july of 2021.
until next time everyone take care be
safe
and thank you bye-bye